bonjour nous sommes en direct ce mardi
pour un sujet très important de la
planète people de la pour les Anglais
c'est la publication des mémoires du
prince Harry et pour en parler je suis
avec Chloé Friedman Chloé Friedman qui a
passé une matinée studieuse à lire ses
mémoires qui sont sorties ce matin Chloé
comment ça va déjà
et bah très bien merci vous attendez
Figaro vous n'hésitez pas tout au long
de ce live bien sûr à poser vos
questions n'essaie d'y répondre au mieux
on ne sera pas accueil du Figaro on est
aussi sur Youtube vous laissez surtout
pas à poser vos questions je vois que
vous êtes déjà nombreux à nous rejoindre
petit à petit Chloé déjà première
question rien ne va plus dans la famille
royale et ce livre le montre une
nouvelle fois alors ça ne va plus
du côté
de enfin du roi Charles III apparemment
il serait dévasté parce qu'effectivement
le prince Harry vient de sortir comme
vous le savez ces mémoires qui sont
sorties aujourd'hui le mardi 10 janvier
et dans lequel il ne mâche pas du tout
ces mots à l'égard de la famille royale
donc apparemment ça aurait ressuscité
pas mal de réactions dans les rangs de
la famille royale même si pour l'instant
il y a pas eu de déclaration officielle
le prince William il serait dévasté il
serait triste il serait anxieux très en
colère mais il aurait pris la décision
de ne pas s'exprimer pour protéger sa
famille
déjà sa famille proche et toute la
famille royale
et effectivement tout la famille royale
en elle-même aurait été ébranlée par cet
ouvrage oui parce que alors le livre
sort aujourd'hui alors déjà on peut
quand même rappeler ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il y a quelques fuites ces
derniers jours c'est ça
fuiter le jeudi 5 janvier il a été vendu
par erreur en Espagne et évidemment les
tableaux ils n'ont pas tardé à mettre la
main dessus donc depuis c'est un peu une
avalanche de nouvelles qui tombe dans la
presse des extraits du livre ont fuité
par design moins alors moi je vous
avouer je ne suis pas vraiment
l'actualité de la famille royale en
temps réel c'est pour ça que je vous
invite d'ailleurs puisque vous êtes un
peu plus spécialiste que moi pourquoi ce
livre est un événement alors c'est un
événement parce que en janvier 2001 2020
pardon il y a eu le Mexique ce qu'on
appelle le Mexique dans les tabloïdes en
tout cas c'est la volonté annoncée de
Meghan Markle et du prince Harry de
quitter leur fonction royale et depuis
il y a eu pas mal de rumeurs dans la
presse sur leur mésentente avec la
famille royale notamment entre les
princes Harry et William
et donc ce livre était attendu pour plus
ou moins confirmer ses rumeurs et aussi
parce que la devise de la famille royale
c'est never complet never explain c'est
à dire ne pas se plaindre ne jamais se
justifier donc ils ont pour habitude de
garder le silence sur tout et c'est
profondément intrigant qu'un prince
ose ainsi défier la règle de la famille
royale et s'exprimer dans un livre où
pour le coup il délivrait énormément
d'anecdotes sur les coulisses de la vie
dans la au sein de la famille royale
alors je salue Christian Léon tout ça
qui me dit qu'il y avait un excellent
documentaire hier soir à 22h30
sur sur ce sujet je salue aussi radio
nationale du Québec avec nous et le lait
manuel Sony ABC qui est aussi avec nous
vous n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
comme je vous le disais alors ce livre
qu'est-ce qu'on y trouve dedans il y a
des révélations alors il y a énormément
de révélations en fait c'était un peu
inattendu à vrai dire toutes ces
révélations parce que le 8 décembre il y
a un documentaire Netflix qui s'appelle
Harry et Meghan qui a été auquel on
collaborait les ce sexe qui est sorti
sur la plateforme de streaming et
c'était peut-être un documentaire en 6
épisodes mais on y apprenait à vrai dire
pas grand chose
c'était assez lisse donc on s'attendait
pas à beaucoup de choses de la part du
prince Harry dans ses mémoires et en
réalité
image pas ses mots sur la famille royale
il qualifie notamment sa belle-mère
camigna de méchante maratre
il évoque le décès de sa mère la manière
dont il a dont il a composé avec le
décès de sa mère il évoque les tensions
qui se sont parfois manifestées
physiquement avec son frère William mais
aussi les rivalités entre donc le couple
ce sexe et le prince William et Kate
Middleton
enfin c'est il évoque même le scandale
de l'affaire Jeffrey epsteen autour du
prince androux chose que aucun membre de
la famille royale à part le prince andro
lui-même n'avait fait auparavant sauf
pour éventuellement le lui enlever ces
titres militaires donc c'est
effectivement assez étonnant en terme
d'avalanche de révélation oui et alors
est-ce que on va parler un peu tout à
l'heure de de ce qui pourrait être un
business on va dire de révélation pour
pour bien comprendre un peu parce que
depuis le début enfin on parle de cette
famille royale il y a des gens qui ne
sont pas forcément est-ce qu'on peut
refaire un peu peut-être pas
l'organigramme mais le comment ça
fonctionne qui est dans cette famille et
qui sont les les protagonistes et bien
les protagonistes c'était donc jusqu'à
son décès la reine Elizabeth II
son fils qui est désormais le roi
Charles III et le père du prince William
et du prince Harry ce qui a donné
d'ailleurs le titre de l'autobiographie
du prince Harry qui s'appelle le
suppléant et donc le suppléant en fait
c'est un référence au statut d'éternel
numéro 2 du prince Harry parce que le
prince William a été élevé comme
l'héritier du trône et le prince Harry
comme entre guillemets sont suppléant
son numéro 2 qui est là éventuellement
pour faire diversion en cas de bêtises
du prince William donc il évoque un peu
la condescendance dont il a pu parfois
être victime de la part de sa propre
famille
et donc il y a William et son frère et
leurs épouses donc William et marié avec
Kate Middleton qui est aujourd'hui
princesse de Galles depuis le décès de
la reine et Meghan Markle qui est
l'épouse du prince Harry et duchesse de
ce sexe et vie désormais donc avec le
prince Harry en Californie depuis qu'ils
ont choisi de quitter leurs engagements
royaux
et d'ailleurs il en parle de sa femme
Meghan mar n'a jamais réussi à comment
dire intégrer dans la famille royale
c'est ça
[Musique]
il explique qu'en fait le surnom qui a
été attribué aux deux couples donc le
couple du prince Harry et le couple du
prince William on les a appelé à
l'époque les femmes fortes c'est à dire
le un groupe de 4 très puissant qui
allait un peu redorer l'image de la
monarchie et en fait il explique que les
femmes Falls ça n'a jamais existé que
c'était une pure invention qu'en fait
dès le départ il y avait des tensions
entre Meghan Markle et Kate Middleton
qui avait un peu une rivalité entre les
deux couples et par ailleurs que Kate
Middleton est le prince William
mettez l'accent sur les stéréotypes
concernant Meghan Markle c'est-à-dire le
fait qu'elle soit une actrice américaine
divorcée métisse et que en fait selon
lui ça aurait créé un obstacle à son
intégration dans la famille royale
d'accord je vois bien alors dans ce
livre alors parce que j'ai un petit
commentaire quand même de pêcheur qui
nous demande quels sont les potins qu'y
a-t-il de croustillants et c'est vrai
qu'on a quand même titré ce live sexe
drogue bagarre on apprend des choses sur
par exemple il dit qu'il s'est déjà
drogué le prince Harry
non il consacre pas mal de passages à
Rogue il dit que il a commencé à
consommer de la cocaïne quand il avait
17 ans il dit qu'il a il a fait ça lors
d'un week-end de chasse parce qu'il
avait envie un peu de s'évader de se
sentir différent après le décès de sa
mère mais il dit aussi qu'il a pas
trouvé ça amusant mais à plusieurs
reprises par la suite dit qu'il s'est un
peu plongé dans l'alcool tout ça pour
composer avec le décès de sa mère c'est
toujours pour cette même raison que il a
pu consommer aussi pas mal de drogues
psychédéliques qu'il a pu par exemple le
consommer des champignons etc il dit
qu'il a fumé des joints jusqu'à ses 36
ans donc oui les il a vraiment pas de
filtre dans cet ouvrage il va même
raconter sa première fois dans ce dans
ce livre si j'ai bien compris il y a des
anecdotes effectivement assez improbable
notamment cette première fois qu'il
aurait fait à 17 ans donc derrière un
pub bondé comme il le raconte dans un
champ avec une femme plus âgée que lui
qui dit-il aimer les machos bien monté
donc c'est effectivement assez cru comme
comme langage et étonnant de la part du
prince Harry mais il y a beaucoup de
d'anecdotes de ce type dans le livre
alors ça peut paraître bizarre on sait
que la famille royale a toujours été
assez comment dire toujours été contre
les tabloïdes qui révélaient la vie
privée le prince Harry l'a été lui aussi
et là il y a un peu un paradoxe on le
voit lui tout déballer maintenant en
fait non il y a complètement en paradoxe
et le prince Harry n'est d'ailleurs pas
à une contradiction près parce que en
mars 2021 il avait donné avec son épouse
une interview à Oprah Winfrey dans
laquelle il évoquait une remarque
raciste formulée de la part d'un membre
de la famille royale
sur la future couleur de peau de son
fils arti
or aujourd'hui dans des interviews à la
télévision il affirme que il n'a jamais
qualifié sa famille de racisme et que en
fait il voulait plutôt parler de
préjugés inconscient
il dit que c'est un peu la presse qui
l'a présenté de cette manière et
effectivement il y a pas mal de
contradictions dans ces interviews et
dans son livre alors on a Cristiano
dans les commentaires qui nous parlent
de de ces révélations est-ce que alors
je vais je vais schématiser un peu ce
qu'il dit mais est-ce que avec ce qui
vit ce qui vient de se passer on a
on a vraiment comment vit la famille
royale un espèce de lumière crue sur la
famille royale alors que leur
communication on le sait millimétré pour
que rien ne sorte et là on a
l'impression que voilà c'est des êtres
humains comme plus parce qu'en fait
complètement et la famille royale est
complètement dévastée comme je vous le
disais
ils ont décidé de ne pas réagir mais en
coulisses ils commencent déjà à prendre
certaines mesures c'est à dire que le
prince Harry par exemple
à Nora apparemment selon le Sunday Times
aucun rôle officiel dans le couronnement
du roi Charles III parce qu'il faut
savoir que ça tombe très mal pour la
famille royale qui prépare le
couronnement du roi Charles III et on ne
sait pas si le prince arrive à y
assister mais en tout cas des sources
anonymes ont dit au Sunday Times que le
prince Harry n'y aurait aucun rôle
officiel d'accord alors c'est un peu la
question on va reparler un peu aussi de
d'autres choses du livre mais qu'est-ce
qui cherche le prince Harry avec ça
parce que il doit bien avoir une idée en
tête comment redorer son blason
peut-être faire quelque chose pourquoi
il fait ça est-ce qu'on arrive à
comprendre un peu ce qui pourrait se
passer alors lui il dans les interviews
que il fait ça pour rétablir la vérité
pour se réapproprier son histoire il dit
qu'en fait ce sont des mémoires
nécessaires qui sont là pour établir des
faits historiques donc il s'agit
vraiment de relater l'effet selon son
point de vue d'accord alors il règle
aussi les contextes son frère dans ce
livre il va parler d'une violente
dispute qu'ils ont eu en 2019 c'est ça
alors il parle de en fait de deux
violentes disputes donc il avait déjà un
peu commencé à aborder ces conflits dans
son documentaire Harry et Megane où il
disait qu'en fait après le mixit ils
avaient eu une dispute assez violente
durant des pour parler sur les termes
justement de l'accord du Mexique que le
prince Harry était terrifié parce que le
prince William lui avait crié dessus et
il était allé un peu plus loin dans son
livre en disant qu'en 2019 à Londres ils
ont eu effectivement une violente
dispute durant laquelle le prince
William a notamment
vérifier le Meghan Markle
d'un poly et
ça se serait envenimer et le prince
William aurait jeté tout bonnement le
prince Harry au sol et il aurait atterri
sur selon ses propres dire sur la
gamelle du chien qui a éclaté en
morceaux et qui lui s'est morceau lui
aurait entaillé le dos et laisser des
éraflures des Bleus etc et il relate une
deuxième dispute qui serait survenue
après les funérailles du prince Philippe
donc ça c'était en avril 2021 ou en fait
ils avaient décidé avec son père et son
frère de se retrouver dans les jardins
de froggmor cottage donc qui était la
qui est toujours d'ailleurs la demeure
du prince Harry en Grande-Bretagne
et ils auraient parlé justement de
l'interview accordée par le prince Harry
à Oprah Winfrey et la conversation ce
serait aussi en venimée et là le prince
William aurait saisi à deux reprises son
frère par le T-shirt assez violemment
de l'écouter et en lui disant malgré
tout qu'il l'aimait qu'il voulait qu'il
soit heureux et là le prince Harry lui
aurait répondu je ne pense pas vraiment
que ce soit le cas alors on n'avale pas
dû dans les commentaires qui me dit quoi
qu'il en ça je trouve minable de salira
si ta famille alors c'est rigolo parce
que justement tout simple trouver sa
viande pour avoir un peu de réalité pour
voir ce qui se passe derrière valent pas
une nous dit que lui il aurait préféré
que tout ça reste un peu secret pour pas
créer de pour pas créer de scandale on
en parle ici tout à l'heure il parle de
sa mère et il parle justement de de
l'accident de sa mère de la mort de sa
mère dans ce livre
c'est assez touchant d'ailleurs il se
confie beaucoup sur le décès de sa mère
et sur la manière dont comme on le
disait tout à l'heure dont il a composé
avec le décès de sa mère il dit qu'en
fait au départ il n'y a tout simplement
pas cru il a eu la pensée que sa mère
avait une vie si triste qu'elle avait
mis en scène sa mort pour pouvoir fuir
sa vie et qu'en fait il avait eu besoin
de demander à son secrétaire particulier
des photos de l'accident pour pouvoir
accepter voilà que que sa mère était
bien morte et donc il dit que son frère
William a lui aussi eu beaucoup de mal
par la suite
à en venir à cette réalité il se disait
plutôt qu'en fait c'était un mensonge et
que ça sa mère se cachait quelque part
alors le prince Harry aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on connaît un peu sa cote de
popularité auprès des anglais parce
qu'on imagine que si je fais ça c'est
pas forcément pour rien mais est-ce
qu'on sait à peu près quelle est sa cote
de popularité
chez nos voisins britanniques alors il y
a eu un récent sondage de la part qui
dit que il est désarmé à 64% d'opinion
négatives chez les Britanniques ce qui
augmente c'est ça
fait de 5 points et au contraire ça cote
positive les ventes donc c'est réduite à
26% et donc à la baissé de 7 points dans
les opinions d'accord donc effectivement
alors l'autre chose qui peut chercher
sinon c'est le business parce que il va
quand même lire aller il va un livre qui
est quand même un best-seller j'imagine
alors pour que vous nous racontiez un
peu comment ça s'est passé mais des
livres comme ça c'est souvent d'embargo
on peut les recevoir en avance mais
quand c'est pas le cas on achète des
livres et par exemple une rédaction
comme le madame va l'acheter en nombre
pour que chacun puisse le lire en fait
alors nous en général on demande à
recevoir les les épreuves à l'avance et
là on n'a pas pu avoir les épreuves à
l'avance donc effectivement on a dû les
lire ce matin mais en fait
tout est tellement sorti dans la presse
que il y a pas vraiment de nouvelles
informations ou alors des petites
anecdotes à la lecture du livre mais ça
reste quand même intéressant de le lire
parce que c'est un livre qui a été
corrigé par un prix Pulitzer qui
s'appelle Jr moringer et donc qui est
très bien rédigé et dans lequel le
prince Harry se montre parfois très
touchant il parle notamment de son
trouble de stress post-traumatique après
avoir été au combat lorsqu'il était
soldat donc il y a des passages quand
même assez touchants dans ce livre alors
la pêcheur qui demande mais comment
avez-vous fait pour lire tout le livre
alors qu'il est sorti ce matin et bien
c'est mis on s'est réparti les chapitres
du livre à vrai dire et on s'est mise à
plusieurs pour pour le décrypter voilà
pour les petits secrets que vous vouliez
peut-être donc
un livre comme ça ça peut lui rapporter
quand même pas mal d'argent à Harry
c'est aussi peut-être ça qui qui cherche
finalement voilà parce que qu'est-ce qui
peut chercher d'autres finalement
alors je pense qu'il cherche avant tout
à dire sa vérité mais c'est vrai que il
a signé un contrat assez juteux quand
même pour publier ses mémoires alors il
faut savoir qu'en plus ces mémoires ce
n'est pas qu'un seul ouvrage il a signé
pour une trilogie et donc il a conclu un
deal à 36 millions de livres sterling
pour cette trilogie et pour le premier
tome il a reçu 20 millions de dollars et
alors ça veut dire qu'il manque encore
des choses est-ce que par exemple il
parle là de de l'enterrement de la Reine
Elizabeth par exemple
et bien non ils n'en parle pas dans ce
livre du mois ma connaissance c'est
peut-être pas votre partie je voulais
pas vous virer sur ça je ne pense pas
qu'il en parle
moi aussi oui voilà donc en fait ça fera
l'objet d'autres livres de sa future
trilogie de sa future autobiographie
c'est justement la question qu'on peut
se
poseront les deux prochains livres parce
qu'il est tellement déjà de révélations
dans la presse dans ce premier tome dans
les interviews à la télévision parce
qu'il a aussi donné deux interviews à
CBS et ITV on peut voilà on peut
légitimement se poser la question de ce
que nous réserve ces deux prochains
vides et puis on verra merci beaucoup en
tout cas d'avoir été avec nous merci à
vous d'avoir du Figaro d'avoir été
nombreux à nous suivre et à poser vos
questions la suite du programme ce sera
à 17h vous avez rendez-vous avec le buzz
TV et à 17h30 ce sera sur la réforme des
retraites Isabelle borne qui présente le
plan de la réforme des retraites on
suivra ça bien évidemment sur le Figaro
et moi je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouveaux live sur fear live